the following is a conversation with
elon musk his third time on this the lex
friedman podcast
yeah make yourself comfortable oh
no wow okay no no
you don't do the headphone thing no okay
i mean how close do i get need to get
this thing the closer you are the sexier
you sound hey babe yeah can't get enough
of the what y'all that baby
i'm gonna clip that out anytime somebody
messages me about it
and you think i'm sexy come right out
and tell me so
so good okay
serious mode activate all right
mode come on you're russian you can be
serious
everyone's serious all the time in
russia yeah
yeah
we'll get there we'll get there
yeah it's gotten soft
allow me to say that the spacex launch
of human beings to orbit on may 30th
2020
was seen by many as the first step in a
new era of human space exploration
these human space flight missions were a
beacon of hope to me and to millions
over the past two years is our world has
been going through one of the most
difficult periods in recent human
history
we saw we see the rise of division fear
cynicism and the loss of common humanity
right when it is needed most so first
elon let me say thank you for giving the
world hope and reason to be excited
about the future oh it's kind of you to
say it
i do want to do that humanity has uh
obviously a lot of issues and and uh you
know people at times do do bad things
but
you know
despite all that um you know i love
humanity and i think we should
uh
make sure we do everything we can to
have a good future and an exciting
future and one where that maximizes the
happiness of the people
let me ask about uh crew dragon demo two
so that that first flight with humans on
board
how did you feel leading up to that
launch were you scared are you excited
what's going through your mind so much
was at stake
yeah no that was extremely stressful no
question
we obviously could not
um
let them down in any way um so
extremely stressful i'd say
uh to say the least
but we did
i was confident that at the time that we
launched that
no one could think of anything
at all to do that would improve the
probability of success
um and we we racked our brains to think
of any possible way to improve the
probability of success we could not
think of anything more and and nor could
nasa and
so then that that's just the best that
we could do so then we we had
we went ahead and launched
now i'm not a religious person
um but i nonetheless got on my knees and
prayed for that mission
you able to sleep
no
how did it feel
when it was a success first when the
launch was a success and when they
returned back home or back to earth
it was a great relief
yeah
it's for high stress situations i find
it's not so much elation as relief
um
and um
you know i think once
as as we we got more comfortable and
improved out the systems because you
know we really
um
you know you got to make sure everything
works um
i was it was definitely a lot more
enjoyable with the subsequent uh
astronaut uh missions
and i thought the
the inspiration mission was was actually
very inspiring um the inspiration for
mission um i'd encourage people to watch
the
inspiration documentary on netflix it's
actually really good um and it really
isn't so i i was actually inspired by
that um and i i i so that one i felt i i
was kind of able to enjoy the the actual
mission and not just be super stressed
all the time so for people that somehow
don't know it's the all civilian first
time
all civilian out to space out to orbit
yeah it was the high i think the highest
orbit that uh in like under 30 or 40
years or something the only one that was
higher
was the one shuttle sorry a hubble uh
servicing mission
um and then before that it would have
been um apollo in 72.
it's pretty wild
so it's cool it's good you know i think
uh as you know
as a species like we want to be
you know continuing to
do better and and reach higher ground
and and like i think it would be tragic
extremely tragic if um apollo was the
high water mark for humanity you know
and that then that's as far as we ever
got
and it's um
it's concerning that here we are um
49 years after the last mission to the
moon
it's almost half a century
uh and we've not been back
um and that's
that's worrying it's like is that
does that mean
we've peaked as a civilization or what
so
like i think we got to get back to the
moon and build a base there you know a
science base i think we could learn a
lot about the nature of the universe if
we have a proper science base on the
moon
um you know like we have a science based
in antarctica and you know many other
parts of the world and
um so that that that's like i think the
next big thing we've got to have like a
serious like moon base um and then get
people to mars and
you know get get out there and
be a space bearing civilization
i'll ask you about some of those details
but since you're so busy with the hard
engineering challenges
of everything that's involved
are you still able to marvel at the
magic of it all of space travel
of every time the rocket goes up
especially when it's a crude mission
or you're just so overwhelmed with the
all the challenges that you have to
solve
and actually sort of to add to that
the reason i want to ask this question
of may 30th it's it's been some time so
you can look back and think about the
impact already it's already at the time
it was an engineering problem maybe now
it's becoming a historic moment like
it's a moment that
how many moments would be remembered
about the 21st century to me
that or something like that maybe
inspiration for one of those would be
remembered as the early steps of a new
age of uh space exploration
yeah i mean during the launches itself
so i mean i think i think maybe some
people know but a lot of people don't
know it's like i'm actually the chief
engineer of spacex so
um
the
you know i've signed off on pretty much
all the design decisions
um and
you know so if there's something that
goes wrong with that
vehicle it's it's fundamentally my fault
you know so
um
so i'm really just thinking
about all the things that like so so
when i see the rocket i see all the
things that could go wrong and the
things that could be better and the same
with the dragon spacecraft it's like
other people say oh this is a
spacecraft or a rocket and this looks
really cool i'm like
i've like a readout of like this is the
these are these are the risks these are
the pro the problems that's what i see
so it's
not what other people see when they see
the product you know so let me uh ask
you then to analyze starship in that
same way i know you have you'll talk
about in more detail about starship in
the near future perhaps yeah talk about
it now if you want um but just in that
same way like you said you see when you
see up
when you see a rocket you see a sort of
a list of risks in that same way you
said that starship is a really hard
problem
so there's many ways i can ask this but
if you magically could solve one problem
perfectly one engineering problem
perfectly which one would it be on sasha
on sorry on starship so is it maybe
related to the efficiency the
uh the engine the weight of the
different components the complexity of
various things maybe the controls of the
the crazy thing has to do to land no
it's actually the by far the the biggest
thing absorbing my time is uh
uh engine production
not not the design of the engine but
i've often said prototypes are
are easy production is hard
so
we have the most advanced rocket engine
that's ever been designed um
the because i say currently the the best
rocket engine ever is probably the rd
180 or rd-170 the um
that that's the russian engine basically
um
and um
and still i think an engine should only
count if it's gotten something to orbit
um
so our engine has not gotten anything to
orbit yet
um but it is it's the first engine
that's actually
better than than the the
russian rd engines which are
amazing design
so you're talking about raptor engine
what makes it amazing what what are the
different aspects of it that
make it like what are you the most
excited about uh if the whole thing
works
in terms of efficiency all those kinds
of things
well it's
the raptor is a
a full flow
uh staged combustion
um
engine and it's
operating at a very high chamber
pressure
so one of the key figures america
perhaps the key figure of merit is
um
what is the chamber pressure at which
the rocket engine can operate that's the
combustion chamber pressure
so a raptor is
designed to operate at 300 bar possibly
maybe higher that's 300 atmospheres so
um
the record right now for operational
engine is the rd engine that i mentioned
the russian rd which is i believe around
267
bar
and the the the difficulty of the
chamber pressure is increases on a
non-linear basis so
10 more
pressure is
more like uh
50
more difficult
um
but that that chain of pressure is that
that is what allows you to get a very
high uh power density
for the engine um so
uh enabling um
a very high thrust to weight ratio
and
a very high specific impulse
so specific impulse is like a measure of
the efficiency of a rocket engine or um
it's really the the
the uh
exhaust the effective exhaust velocity
of of the gas coming out of the engine
um
so uh
with a very high chamber pressure you
can have um
a
a compact engine that nonetheless has a
high expansion ratio which is the ratio
between the uh
exit nozzle
uh and the uh
throat so you know engine's got like you
see a rocket just got like sort of like
about like a hourglass shape it's like a
chamber and then it next down and
there's a nozzle and the ratio of the
the exit diameter to the
throat
expansion ratio so why is it such a hard
engine to manufacture
at scale
uh it's very complex
so a lot of what does complexity mean
here's a lot of components involved
there's a lot of a lot of components and
a lot of
uh unique materials
that so we had to invent a
several alloys that don't exist in order
to make this engine work
um
materials problem too
it's a materials problem and um it is in
a staged combustion a full flow stage
combustion there there are many uh
feedback loops in the system so
you uh
basically you've got
uh
propellant and and and uh hot gas
flowing
um
simultaneously to so many different
places on the engine
and
they all have a recursive effect on each
other so you change one thing here it
has a recursive effect here it changes
something over there and and it's
it's it's quite
hard to control um
like there's a reason no one's made this
before um
but
um
and the reason we're doing um a
stage combustion uh
full flow
is because it it has the highest uh the
highest uh
theoretical possible uh efficiency
um
so
in in in order to make a fully reusable
rocket
um
which that's the really the holy grail
of orbital rocketry um
you have to have
everything's got to be the best uh it's
got to be the best engine the best
airframe the best heat shield um
extremely light uh avionics
um
you know very clever control mechanisms
um you've got to shed mass in in any
possible way that you can um for example
instead of putting landing legs on the
booster and chip we are going to catch
them with a tower to save the weight of
the landing lens
legs so that's like
i mean
we're talking about catching
the largest flying object ever made
uh with
on a giant tower with with chopstick
arms
it's like karate kid with the fly but
much bigger
i mean pulling this probably
won't work the first time
uh and anyway so this is bananas this is
banana stuff so you mentioned that you
doubt well not you doubt but there
there's days or moments when you doubt
that this is even possible
it's so difficult the possible part is
well at this point
we'll i think we will get starship to
work
um
um there's a question of timing how long
will it take us to do this
how long will it take us to actually
achieve a full and rapid reusability
because it will take probably many
launches before we are able to have full
and rapid reusability
but i can't say that that the physics
pencils out like the like we're not uh
like at this point i'd say we're
confident that that
like let's say
i'm very confident success is in the set
of all possible outcomes
for a while there i was not convinced
that success was in the set of possible
outcomes
which is very important actually
but so um
saying there's a chance i'm saying
there's a chance exactly um
uh just not sure how
how how
long it will take uh
we're very very talented team they're
working night and day to make it happen
um
and uh
and like like i said the the the
critical thing to achieve for the
revolution in space flight and for
humanity to be a space frank
civilization is to have a fully and
rapidly reusable rocket oval rocket
there's not even been any orbital rocket
that's been fully reusable ever and this
has always been the
the the holy grail of rocketry
and
many smart people very smart people
have tried to do this before and have
not succeeded so
um because it's such a hard problem
what's your source of belief
in situations like this
when the engineering problem is so
difficult there's a lot of experts
many of whom you admire who have failed
in the past yes
and
um
a lot of people
you know
a lot of experts maybe journalists all
the kind of you know the public in
general have a lot of doubt about
whether it's possible
and you yourself know that even if it's
a non-null set not empty set
of success it's still unlikely or very
difficult like where do you go to both
personally
um intellectually as an engineer as a
team
like for source of strength needed to
sort of persevere through this
and to keep going with the project take
it to completion
a source of strength hmm i i just really
not how i think about things
um
i mean for me it's simply this this is
something that is important to get done
um
and we we should just keep doing it um
or die trying
and i
i don't need
a source of strength so quitting is not
even like um
that's not it's not my nature okay and i
i don't
care about optimism or pessimism
[ __ ] that we're gonna get it done gonna
get it done
can you uh then zoom back in to specific
problems with starship or any
engineering problems you work on
can you try to introspect your
particular biological neural network
your thinking process and describe how
you think
through problems the different
engineering and design problems is there
like a systematic process you've spoken
about first principles thinking but is
there kind of a process to it well um
you know like saying like like physics
is law and everything else is a
recommendation
um like i've met a lot of people who can
break the law but i haven't met anyone
who could break physics
so uh so first for you know any kind of
technology problem you have to sort of
just make sure you're not
violating
physics um
and you know uh
first principles analysis i think is
something that can be applied to
really any walk of life uh any anything
really it's just it's it's really just
saying um
you know let's let's well something down
to the most fundamental
uh
principles the things that we are most
confident are true at a foundational
level
and that sets you at your sets your
axiomatic base and then you reason up
from there and then you cross-check your
conclusion against the the axiomatic
truths
um
so
um you know some basics in physics would
be like are you violating conservation
of energy or momentum or something like
that you know then
it's not gonna work
um
so
uh that's
you know so that's just to establish is
it is it possible
and then another good physics tool is
thinking about things in the limit if
you if you take a particular thing and
you
uh
scale it to a very large number or to a
very small number how does how do things
change
um well it's like tempo like in number
of things you manufacture something like
that and then in time
yeah like let's say say the example of
like um
like manufacturing which i think is just
a very underrated
problem um
and and
uh likes it it's it's much harder to
take
an advanced technology product and bring
it into volume manufacturing than it is
to design it in the first place my
orders magnitude so
um
so let's say you're trying to figure out
is
like why is this
this uh
part or product
expensive is it um
because of something fundamentally
foolish that we're doing or is it
because our volume is too low and so
then you say okay well what if our
volume was a million units a year is it
still expensive that's what i'm
radically thinking about things to the
limit if it's still expensive at a
million units a year then volume is not
the reason why your thing is expensive
there's something fundamental about
design
and then you then can focus on the
reducing complexity or something like
that and change the design to change
changes apart to be something that is uh
uh
not fundamentally expensive
but like that's a common thing in
rocketry because the the unit volume is
relatively low and so a common excuse
would be well it's expensive because our
unit volume is low um and if we were in
like automotive or something like that
or consumer electronics then our costs
would be lower and like i'm like okay so
let's say we skip now you're making a
million units a year is it still
expensive if the answer is yes
then
uh
economies of scale are not the issue
do you throw
into manufacturing do you throw like
supply chain you talk about resources
and materials and stuff like that do you
throw that into the calculation of
trying to reason from first principles
like how we're going to make the supply
chain work here
yeah yeah and then the cost of materials
things like that or is that too much
exactly so um like another like a good
example of thinking about things uh in
the limit is
um if you take any uh
you know any any
product any machine or whatever um
like take a rocket or whatever
and
say uh if you've got if you look at the
room
raw materials in the rocket
um so you're gonna have like uh
aluminum steel titanium inconel
especially specialty alloys um
copper and and you say what are the
how
what what's the weight of the
constituent elements of each of these
elements and what is their raw material
value
and that sets the
asymptotic limit for how
low the cost of the vehicle can be
unless you change the materials
so
and then when you do that i call it like
maybe the magic wand number or something
like that so that would be like if you
had the
you know a like just a pile of these raw
materials here and you could wave magic
wand and rearrange the atoms into the
final shape
um
that would be the
lowest possible cost that you could make
this thing for unless you change the
materials
so then and that is always a you're
almost always a very low number
um
so then the what's actually causing
these to be expensive is how you put the
atoms into the desired shape
yeah actually if you don't mind me
taking a tiny tangent i had uh i often
talked to jim keller who was somebody
that worked with you oh yeah that's a
fantastic job jim was
yeah did great work at tesla
so
um i suppose he carries the flame of the
same kind of thinking that you're you're
talking about now
um and i guess i see that same thing at
tesla
and spacex folks who work there they
kind of learn this way of thinking and
it kind of becomes obvious almost
but anyway i had um argument not
argument
uh he educated me
about
how cheap it might be to manufacture
teslabot we just we had an argument what
is how can you reduce the cost of scale
of
producing a robot because i've gotten a
chance to interact quite a bit um
obviously in in the academic circles
with humanoid robots and then boston
dynamics and stuff like that and they're
very expensive to to build
and then uh jim kind of schooled me on
saying like okay like this kind of first
principle is thinking of how can we get
the cost of manufacturing down
um i suppose you do that you have done
that kind of thinking for teslabot and
for all kinds of
all kinds of complex systems that are
traditionally seen as complex and you
say okay how can we simplify everything
down
yeah
i mean i think if you are really good at
manufacturing
you can basically
make at high volume you can basically
make anything for a cost
that asymptotically approaches the real
raw material value of the constituents
plus any intellectual property that you
need to license
anything right
but it's hard it's not like that's a
very hard thing to do but but it is
possible for anything
anything in volume can be made
like i said for a class
that asymptotically approaches raw
material uh constituents
plus intellectual property license
rights
so what will often happen in trying to
design a product is people will start
with the tools and and parts and methods
that they are familiar with
and then
and try to create a product using their
existing tools and methods
the other way to think about it is
actually imagine the try to imagine the
platonic ideal of the perfect product or
technology whatever it might be
and so what is this what is the perfect
arrangement of atoms
that would be the the best possible
product
and now let us try to figure out how to
get the atoms in that shape
i mean it's it sounds um
it's almost like a rick and morty absurd
until you start to really think about it
and
you really should
think about it in this way because
everything else is kind of uh
if you if you think uh
you you might fall victim to the
momentum of the way things are done in
the past unless you think in this way
well just as a function of inertia
people will
want to use the same tools and methods
that they are familiar with
um
they just that's what they'll do by
default yeah and then that will lead to
an outcome of things that can be made
with those tools and methods but it is
unlikely to be the
platonic idea of the perfect product
um
so
then so that's why it's good to think of
things in both directions they're like
what can we build with the tools that we
have but then but but also what is the
what is the perfect the theoretical
perfect product look like and that that
theoretical perfect part is going to be
a moving target because as you learn
more
the definition of or or for that perfect
product will change because you don't
actually know what the perfect product
is but you can successfully approximate
a more perfect product
so the thing about it like that and then
saying okay now what tools methods
materials whatever do we need to
create in order to get the atoms in that
shape but for people
rarely think about it that way
but it's a powerful tool
i should mention that the brilliant
siobhan zillis is hanging on
hanging out with us
in case you hear a voice of uh wisdom
from uh
from from outside from up above
okay so let me ask you about mars you
mentioned it would be great for science
to put
um a base on the moon to do some
research
but
the truly big leap again in this
category of seemingly impossible is to
put a human being on mars
when do you think spacex will land a
human being on mars
hmm
best case is about five years
worst case tenures
what are the determining factors would
you say from an engineering perspective
or is that that not the bottlenecks
uh you know it's fundamentally um
you know engineering the the vehicle um
i mean starship is the most
complex and advanced rocket that's ever
been made by
i don't know order of magnitude or
something like that it's a lot
it's really next level so
um
and the fundamental optimization of
starship is minimizing cost per ton to
orbit and ultimately cost per ton to the
surface of mars
um this may seem like a mercantile
objective but it is actually the thing
that needs to be optimized
um like there is a certain
cost per tonne to the surface of mars
where we can afford to establish a
self-sustaining uh city
um and
and then above that we cannot afford to
do it um so right right now you couldn't
fly to mars for a trillion dollars
doesn't no amount of money could get
your ticket to mars
so we need to get that above
uh you know to get that like something
that is actually possible at all um
um
but but then but that's that's
we don't just want to have
you know with mars flags and footprints
and then not come back for a half
century like we did with the moon
uh
in order to pass
a very important great filter i think we
need to be a multi-planet species
um
this may sound somewhat esoteric to
to a lot of people but
uh
like eventually given enough time
uh
that's something
the earth is likely to experience
some calamity um that could be
uh
something that humans do to themselves
or an external event like happen to the
dinosaurs
um
and
um but a bit of you know eventually
and if nothing if none of that happens
and somehow magically we keep going
then the sun will the sun is gradually
expanding
um and will engulf the earth um and
probably earth gets too hot for
uh life in
uh
about 500 million years it's a long time
but that's only
10 longer than earth has been around
and so if you think about like the
because the current situation is really
remarkable um and kind of hard to
believe but
uh
it's been around four and a half billion
years and this is the first time if one
half billion years that has been
possible to extend life beyond earth
and that window opportunity may be open
for a long time and i hope it is but it
also may be open for a short time and we
should uh i think it was
wise for us to
uh
act quickly while the window is open
just in case it closes
yeah the existence of nuclear weapons
pandemics
all kinds of threats yeah
should uh should kind of um
give us some motivation
i mean civilization could get
um
could die with a bang or a whimper
you know if it's uh
if it dies a demographic collapse then
it's more of a whimper
obviously
but if it's world war three it's more of
a bang
but but these are all risks
um i mean it's important to think of
these things and just
you know think of things as like
probabilities not certainties um there's
a certain probability that
something bad will happen on earth like
i think most likely the future will be
good um
but there's like let's say for
argument's sake um a one percent chance
per century of
of a civilization ending event like that
was stephen hawking's estimate
um
i think he's he might be right about
that
uh so
then uh
you know we should basically
think of this like being a multi-planet
species just like taking out insurance
for life itself like life insurance for
life
[Laughter]
so it's turned into an infomercial real
quick life insurance for life yes
um and you know we we can bring the the
the creatures from uh you know plants
and animals from earth to mars and
breathe life into the planet um
and and have a second planet with with
life um
that would be great um they can't bring
themselves there you know so if we don't
bring them to mars
then they will just
for sure all die when the sun expands
anyway and then that'll be it what do
you think is the most difficult aspect
of building a civilization on mars
terraforming mars like from engineering
perspective from a financial perspective
human perspective to get
get a large number of folks there
who will never return back to earth
uh no they could certainly return some
will return back to earth they will
choose to stay there for the rest of
their lives yeah many will um
but uh we you know we
we need the spaceships back like the
ones that go to mars read them back so
you can hop on if you want you know it's
like but we can't just not have the
spaceships come back those things are
expensive we need them i'd like to come
back and do another trip i mean do you
think about the terraforming aspect like
actually building are you so focused
right now on the spaceships part that's
so critical yeah tomorrow
we absolutely if you can't get there
nothing else matters
so
and like i said
we can't get there with
at some extraordinarily high cost i mean
the current cost of
um let's say
one ton to the surface of mars is on the
order of a billion dollars
so
because you don't just need the rocket
and the launch and everything you need
like heat shield you need you know
guidance system you need deep space
communications you need some kind of
landing system
so like rough approximation would be
a billion dollars per ton to the surface
of mars right now
um this is obviously
um
way too expensive to create a
self-sustaining civilization
um
so we need to improve that by
at least a factor of a thousand
a million per ton
yes ideally less than much less than a
million ton but if it's not
like it's got to be
say if i say like what well how much can
society affords to spend or want to just
want to spend on a self-sustaining
city on mars the self-sustaining part is
important like it's just the key
threshold
um the grateful to
will will have been passed
when the city on mars
it can survive even if the spaceships
from earth stop coming for any reason
doesn't matter what the reason is but if
they stop coming for any reason will it
die out will it not and if there's even
one critical ingredient missing then
it still doesn't count it's like
you know if you're on a long sea voyage
and you've got everything except vitamin
c
and it's only a matter of time you know
you're going to die
so so we're going to get mars city to
the point where it's self-sustaining
um i'm not sure this will really happen
in my lifetime but i i hope to see it at
least have a lot of momentum
and and then you could say okay what is
the minimum tonnage necessary to
have a self-sustaining city um
and there's a lot of uncertainty about
this you could say like i don't know
it's probably at least a million tons
um
because you have to set up a lot of
infrastructure on on mars
like i said you can't be missing any
anything that
in order to be self-sustaining you can't
be missed like you need you know
semiconductor
fabs you need
iron ore refineries like you need lots
of things you know so
um and mars is not super hospitable it's
it's the least inhospitable planet but
it's definitely a fixer-upper of a
planet outside of earth
yeah the earth is pretty earth is like
easy
yeah and also we should clarify in the
solar system yes in the solar system
there might be nice
like vacation spots there might be some
great planets out there but
it's hard to get there yeah way way way
way too hard
to say at least let me push back on that
not really a pushback but a quick
curveball of a question so you did
mention physics as the the first
starting point so
um
general relativity allows for wormholes
uh they technically can exist do you
think um those can ever be leveraged by
humans to travel faster than the speed
of light
well
are you saying the whole thing is
debatable uh the
that we currently do not know of any
means of going faster than the speed of
light
uh
there is like
like
there are some ideas about
having space like so so
you can only move at the speed of light
through through space but
if you can make space itself move
that that's like that that's
warping space
um space is is capable of moving faster
than the speed of light
right
uh like the universe in the big bang the
universe the universe expanded at much
much more than the speed of light
by a lot yeah um
so um
but the
if this is possible the the amount of
energy required towards space is so
gigantic it's boggles the mind
so all the work you've done with
propulsion how much innovation is
possible with rocket propulsion is this
um
i mean you've seen it all and you're
constantly innovating in every aspect
how much is possible like how much can
you get 10x somehow is there something
in there in physics
that you can get significant improvement
in terms of efficiency of engines and
all those kinds of things
well as i'm saying like the
really the holy grail is a fully and
rapidly reusable orbital system um
so
uh right now uh
the
falcon 9 is the only reusable rocket out
there that but it but
the the booster comes back and lands and
you've seen the videos and we get the
nose cone or faring back but we do not
get the upper stage back
so
uh
that means that we have a minimum cost
of
building up for stage um
you can think of like a two-stage rocket
of sort of like two airplanes like a big
airplane and a smaller airplane
um and we get big airplane back but not
the smaller airplane and so it still
costs a lot you know so that upper stage
is
you know at least 10 million dollars
um
and then the
degree of the the booster is not as
reused it's not as rapidly and
completely reusable as we'd like in
order of the fairings so
you know our kind of
minimum marginal cost not counting
overhead for per flight is on the order
of
15
to 20 million dollars maybe
um so
uh that's that's extremely good for
it's by far better than any rocket ever
in history um
but
uh
with full and rapid reusability we can
reduce the cost per ton to orbit by
uh a factor of a hundred
but just think of it like um
like imagine if you had an aircraft or
something or a car
oh yeah and if you had to
buy a new car every time you went for a
drive it would be very expensive
it'll be silly frankly
but
um but you in fact you just refuel the
car or recharge the car
and that's uh makes your trip
like
i don't know a thousand times cheaper
so
it's the same for rockets uh if you
it's
very difficult to make this complex
machine that can go to orbit
and so if you cannot reuse it and if you
have to throw even any part of any
significant part of it away that
massively increases the cost
so
you know starship in theory could do
a cost per launch of like a million
maybe two million dollars or something
like that
um
and uh
and put over 100 tons in orbit
which is crazy yeah
so that's incredible so you're saying
like it's uh by far the biggest bang for
the buck is to make it fully reusable
versus like some kind of
brilliant breakthrough in theoretical
physics
no no there's no there's no brilliant
break no there's no
it just me you're gonna make the rocket
reusable this is an extremely difficult
insuring problem
got it uh but no no new physics is
required
just brilliant engineering let me ask a
slightly philosophical fun question
gotta ask i know you're focused on
getting to mars but once we're there on
mars what do you what form of government
economic system
political system do you think would work
best for an early civilization of humans
is the i mean
the the interesting reason to talk about
this stuff it also make helps people
dream about the future i know you're
really focused about
the short-term engineering dream but
it's like i don't know there's something
about imagining an actual civilization
on mars that gives people
it really gives people hope well it
would be a new frontier and an
opportunity to rethink the whole nature
of government just as was done in the
creation of the united states
so
i mean i would suggest
having a
direct democracy like people vote
directly on things as opposed to
representative democracy so
uh representative democracy i think is
too
uh subject to a special interest and
you know a coercion of the politicians
and that kind of thing um
so i i'd recommend
uh
that that there's just
um direct democracy people vote on laws
the population votes on laws themselves
and then the laws must be short enough
that people can understand them
yeah and then like keeping a
well-informed populist like really being
transparent about all the information
about what they're voting for absolute
transparency yeah and not make it as
annoying as those cookies we have to
accept
cookies like always like
you know there's like always like a
slight amount of trepidation when you
click accept cookies like i feel as
though there's like perhaps like a like
a very tiny chance that'll open a portal
to hell or something like that that's
exactly how i feel why why do they why
do they keep wanting to accept that what
do they want with this cookie
like somebody got upset with accepting
cookies or something somewhere
who cares like
so annoying to keep accepting all these
cookies to me this is just
a great exception yes you can have my
damn cookie i don't care whatever
you heard it from me on first he accepts
all your damn cookies yeah
and start asking me
annoying
yeah it's uh it's
one example of um
implementation of a good idea done
really horribly yeah it's somebody was
like there's some good intentions of
like privacy or whatever but now
everyone's just has to take accept
cookies and it's not you know you have
billions of people who have to keep
clicking except cookie it's super
annoying
then we just accept the damn cookie it's
fine
there is like um
i think a fundamental problem that we're
because we've not really had a
a major
uh like a world war or something like
that in a while and obviously we would
like to not have world wars um
the there's not been a cleansing
function for rules and regulations um
so wars did have uh you know some sort
of lining in that there would be a a
reset on rules and regulations uh after
a war um so world wars one and two there
were huge resets on rules and
regulations
now as
for if the society society does not have
a war
and there's no cleansing function or
garbage collection for rules and
regulations then rules and regulations
will accumulate every year because
they're immortal there's no actual
humans die but the laws don't so
we need a garbage collection function
for rules and regulations they should
not just
be immortal um because some of the rules
and regulations that are put in place
will be counterproductive uh done with
good intentions but counterproductive
sometimes not done with good intentions
so
um if you just if rules and regulations
just accumulate every year
and you get more and more of them then
eventually you won't be able to do
anything you're just like gulliver with
you know tied down by thousands of
little strings
and we had we see that in
um you know
us and
like basically all economies that uh
have been around for for a while
uh and and regulators and legislators
create new rules and regulations every
year but they don't put effort into
removing them and i think that's very
important that we put effort into
removing rules and regulations
um
but it gets tough because you get
special interests that then are
dependent on like they they have a
you know a uh
vested interest in that whatever rule
and regulation and that they then they
fight
to not get it removed
um
yeah so it i mean i guess the problem
with the constitution is it's it's kind
of like c
versus java because it doesn't have any
garbage collection built in i think
there should be i when you first said
the the the metaphor of garbage
collection from a coding standpoint from
the colony standpoint yeah yeah i it
would be interesting interesting if the
laws themselves kind of had a built-in
thing where they kind of die after a
while unless somebody explicitly
publicly defends them yeah so that
that's sort of it's not like somebody
has to kill them they kind of die
themselves they disappear yeah
um
not to defend java or anything but you
know the c plus plus you know you could
also have a great garbage collection in
python and so on
yeah so yeah something's good something
needs to happen
or or just the the civilization's
arteries arteries just harden over time
and and you can just get less and less
done because there's just a rule against
everything
so yeah i think like i don't know for
mars order i'd say or even for you
obviously for earth as well like i think
there should be an active process for
removing
rules and regulations and questioning
their existence
just um
like if we've got a function for
creating rules and regulations because
rules and regulations can also think of
as like they're like software or lines
of code for operating
uh civilization that's the rules and
regulations um
so it's like we shouldn't have rules and
regulations but you have code
accumulation but no code removal
um and so it just gets
to become basically archaic bloatware
after a while
um and and it's just it makes it hard
for
things to progress
so
i don't know maybe mars you'd have like
an uh
you know any given law must have a
sunset you know and and and uh and
require active
voting to keep
restoring to keep it up there you know
um and i actually also say like
and these just i don't know
recommendations or thoughts and
ultimately we'll be up to the people on
mars to decide but
i think um
it should be easier to remove a law than
to add one because of the just to
overcome the inertia of laws
so
maybe it's like uh
for argument's sake you need like say 60
percent vote to have a law take effect
but only a 40 vote to remove it
so let me be the guy you posted meme on
twitter recently where there's
there's like a row of urinals a guy just
walks all the way across
and he tells you about crypto
listen i mean that's happened to me
so many times i think maybe even
literally uh yeah
do you think technologically speaking
there's any room for ideas of smart
contracts or so on because you mentioned
laws
um that's an interesting implement use
of things like smart contracts to
implement the laws by which governments
function
like something built on ethereum or
maybe
a dog coin that enables smart contracts
somehow i never i don't quite understand
this whole smart contract thing um you
know
i mean
so it's two dumb times to have small
contracts
it's a good line
i mean my general approach to any kind
of like deal or whatever is just make
sure there's clarity of understanding
that's the most important thing
um and and just keep any kind of deal
very very short and simple plain
language
and just make sure everyone understands
this is the deal does everyone is it
clear
and uh
and and what are the consequences if
various things don't happen um
but usually deals are um
you know business deals or whatever are
way too long and complex and overly
lawyered and pointlessly
you mentioned that uh doge is the
people's coin
yeah and you said that you were
literally going spacex
may
consider literally putting
uh a dosh coin on
the moon
is this something you're still
considering uh mars perhaps
do you think there's some chance we've
talked about political systems on mars
that uh dogecoin is the
official currency of mars that's coming
in the future
well
i think mars itself will need to have a
different currency because you can't
synchronize due to speed of light
or not easily um so it must be
completely standalone from earth
well yeah because the
but
mars is at closest approach it's four
light minutes away roughly and then at
furthest approach uh it's roughly 20
light minutes away
uh maybe a little more um
so you can't really have something
synchronizing you know if you could if
if you've got a 20 minute speed light
issue if it's got a one minute
blockchain uh it's not going to
synchronize properly
um
so mars really would i don't know if
mars would have a cryptocurrency as a
thing but probably seems likely
but it would be some kind of localized
thing on mars
and you let the people decide
yeah
absolutely
the future of mars should be up to the
martians
yeah so um
i mean i think the cryptocurrency thing
is an interesting
approach to
reducing the um
error in the
the database that is called money
um
you know i think i have a pretty deep
understanding of the of what money
actually is on a practical day-to-day
basis because of paypal
um you know i really
got in deep there um
and
right now the money system actually for
practical purposes is
is really a bunch of uh heterogeneous uh
mainframes running uh old cobalt
okay you mean literally that's literally
that is literally what's happening in
batch mode
okay in patch mode yeah uh pretty the
poor fastest who have to
maintain that code okay that's a
that's a pain that's pain not even for
trans cobalt yep it's cobalt it's like
and they still
banks are still buying mainframes in
2021 and running ancient global code
uh and uh
you know the the federal reserve is like
probably even older than the what the
banks have and they have an old kobold
mainframe
and so now and and so the the government
effectively has editing privileges on
the on the money database
um and they use those editing privileges
to um
make more money
whenever they want
and this increases the error in the
database that is money so i think money
should really be viewed through the lens
of information theory
and uh and so it's uh
you're kind of like uh like an internet
connection like what's the bandwidth uh
you know
total bit rate uh what is the latency
judder
uh packet drop uh you know
errors in errors in the network uh
communication
using money like that basically
um i think that's probably why i really
think of it
and and then say what what system
uh
from an information theory standpoint
allows an economy to function the best
uh
and
you know um
crypto is an attempt to reduce the
the error
uh in
uh in money that is contributed by
uh governments uh
diluting the money supply
as basically a pernicious pernicious
form of taxation
so both policy in terms of with
inflation and actual like technological
cobalt like cryptocurrency takes us into
the 21st century in terms of the actual
systems that allow you to do the
transaction to store wealth all those
kinds of things
like i said just think of money as
information people um often will think
of money as having power in and of
itself um it does not money is uh is
information and it it does not have
power in and of itself
uh
the like the you know again applying the
physics
tools of thinking about things in the
limit
is helpful if you are stranded on a
tropical island
um and uh
you have a trillion dollars it's useless
because there's no there's no resource
allocation
money is a database for resource
allocation
but there's no resources to allocate
except yourself
so money is useless
um
uh
if you're surrounded on desert island
with
no food you'd uh all the bitcoin in the
world
will
not stop you from starving yeah
so
um
so like just think of money as as a
database for resource allocation um
across time and space
and
um and then what what what system
uh it is what what
in what form should that that
database or data system
what what what would be most effective
now
there's a there is a fundamental issue
with um say bitcoin in its current form
uh in that it's the transaction volume
is very limited
um
and uh the
latency this is the latency for for a
properly confirmed transaction is to is
too long much longer than you'd like
so it's not it's actually not great from
um
a transaction volume standpoint or a
latency standpoint
um
uh so it is perhaps useful as
as to search to solve an aspect of the
money database problem uh
which is the sort of store of wealth or
an
accounting of
relative obligations i suppose
but it is not useful as a
currency as a day-to-day currency but
people have proposed different
technological solutions
yeah lightning network and the layer two
technologies on top of that i mean it's
it's all it seems to be all kind of a
trade-off but the point is it's kind of
brilliant to say that just think about
information think about what kind of
database what kind of infrastructure
enables yeah like you're operating an
economy
um
and you need to have some
thing that
allows for the efficient
to have efficient
uh value ratios between products and
services so you've got this massive
number of products and services and you
need to
you can't just bar barter it's like that
would be extremely unwieldy
so you need something that gives you the
the
an
a
a
ratio of exchange between goods and
services
um
and and then something that allows you
to
uh shift obligations across time like
debt debt and equity shift obligations
across time then what does what does the
best job of that
um
part reason why i think there's some
um merit to dogecoin even though it was
obviously created as a joke um
is that
it it actually does have a much higher
uh transaction volume capability than
bitcoin um
and the you know the cut like the costs
of doing a transaction the the dogecoin
fee is is very low like right now if you
want to do a bitcoin transaction the
price of doing that transaction is very
high so you could not use it effectively
for most things
um and nor could it even scale to a high
volume um
uh
and when bitcoin was you know started i
guess when around 2008 or something like
that um
the internet connections were much worse
than they are today like order of
magnitude cup
i mean there's the way way worse you
know in 2008 so so like having us you
know a small
uh block size or whatever is
you know and a long
synchronization time is
made sense in 2008 but did you know 2021
or fast forward 10 years it's like it's
it's like
comically low you know it's uh
so
um
and i think there's some
value to
having
a linear increase in the amount of
currency that uh is generated um
so because some amount of the currency
like like
if a currency is too deflationary or
like uh or should say if if
if if a currency is expected to increase
in value over time there's reluctance to
spend it
because they're like oh i if i
i'll just hold it and not spend it
because it's scarcity is increasing with
time so if i spend it now then i will
regret spending it so i will just you
know total it
but if there's
some dilution of the currency occurring
over time that's that's more of an
incentive to use that as a currency so
um those coins somewhat randomly has
uh
a
um
just a fixed a number of
of
sort of coins or hash strings that
uh
are generated every year so there's
there's some inflation but it's not a
percentage base it's a it's so the
it's a fixed number so the percentage of
inflation will necessarily decline over
time
um
so it just i'm not saying that it's like
the ideal system for a currency but i
think it actually is uh just
fundamentally better than
anything else i've seen just by accident
um so i like how you said um around 2008
so you're not uh
you know some people suggested you might
be satoshi nakamoto you previously said
you're not i'm not
would you tell us if you were yes okay
uh do you think it's a feature of bug
that he's anonymous or she or they
it's an interesting kind of quirk of
human history that there is a particular
technology that is a completely
anonymous inventor
or creator
well i mean you can you can look at the
um
evolution of ideas
um before the launch of bitcoin
and
see who wrote
you know about those ideas
um and then
i like i don't know exactly obviously i
don't know who created bitcoin for
practical purposes but
the evolution of ideas is is pretty
clear before that and like it seems as
though like nick zabo uh is probably
more than anyone else uh responsible for
the evolution of those ideas so
he claims not to be
nakamoto but
i'm not sure that's that's neither here
nor there uh but he he seems to be the
one more responsible for the ideas
behind bitcoin than anyone else
so it's not perhaps like singular
figures aren't even as important as the
the figures involved in the evolution of
ideas that led to a thing so yeah yeah
it's you know and most perhaps it's sad
to think about history but maybe most
names will be forgotten anyway what is
the name anyway it's a name a name
attached to an idea
what does it even mean really i think
shakespeare had a thing about roses and
stuff whatever he said arose by any
other name it smells sweet
i gotta underquote shakespeare i feel i
feel like i accomplished something today
shall i compare it to a summer's day
[Laughter]
i'm gonna clip that
uh
out
more tempered animal fare
[Laughter]
autopilot
tesla
[Laughter]
tesla autopilot has been through an
incredible journey over the past six
years um or perhaps even longer in the
minds of in your mind in the minds of
many involved
uh i think that's where we first like
connected really with the autopilot
stuff autonomy and
the whole journey was incredible to me
to watch
i was um
because i knew well part of as i was at
mit and i i knew the difficulty of
computer vision yeah and i knew the
whole i had a lot of colleagues and
friends about the darpa challenge i knew
how difficult it is and so there was a
natural skepticism when i first drove a
tesla with uh the initial system based
on mobile eye yeah i thought there's no
way
the first one i got in i thought there's
no way this car could maintain
um like stay in the lane and create a
comfortable experience so my intuition
initially was that the lane keeping
problem is way too difficult to solve
oh thank you yeah that's relatively easy
well yeah but like uh but not this but
solve in the way that we just we talked
about previous is prototype
versus a thing that actually creates a
pleasant experience over hundreds of
thousands of miles or millions
a lot of code around the mobile eye
thing it doesn't just work by itself yes
i mean there's part that's part of the
story of how you approach things
sometimes sometimes you do things from
scratch sometimes at first you kind of
see what's out there and then you decide
to from scratch that was
one of the boldest decisions i've seen
is both on the hardware and the software
to decide to eventually go from scratch
i thought again i was skeptical whether
that's going to be able to work out
because it's such a such a difficult
problem
and so it was an incredible journey what
i see now with um
everything the hardware the compute the
sensors the
the things i
maybe care and love about most is the
the stuff that andre karpathy is leading
with the data set selection the whole
data engine process the neural network
architectures the the way that's in the
real world
that network is tested validated all the
different test sets
uh you know versus the image net model
of computer vision like what's in
academia is like real world artificial
intelligence so
um
andrei's awesome and obviously plays an
important role but we have
a lot of really talented people driving
things so
um and uh ashok is actually the head of
autopilot engineering um
uh
andre is the director of ai ai stuff
yeah yeah so yeah there's i'm aware that
there's an incredible team of just a lot
going on yeah just uh you know as people
people will give off will give me too
much credit and they'll give andre too
much credit so
and people should realize how much is
going on under the yeah it's just a lot
of really talented people um
the tesla autopilot ai team is extremely
talented it's like
some of the smartest people in the world
so yeah we're getting it done
what are some insights you've gained
over those
five six years of autopilot about the
problem of autonomous driving so
you leaped in
having some sort of first principles
kinds of intuitions but nobody knows
how
difficult the problem yeah like
i thought the self-driving problem would
be hard but it's it was harder than i
thought it's not like i thought it'd be
easy i thought it'd be very hard but it
was
actually way harder than than even that
so
i mean what it comes down to at the end
of the day is to solve self-driving
uh you have to solve
uh
you you basically
need to recreate
um what you what humans do to drive
which is humans drive with
optical sensors eyes and biological
neural nets
um and so in order to that that's how
the entire road system is designed to
work with with uh
basically passive optical
and neural nets
um
it biologically um and now that we need
to it so for actually for full-size
driving to work we have to recreate that
in digital form
um so we have to
um that that means cameras with uh
advanced uh
neural nets in silicon form
uh
and and then you it will obviously solve
for full self-driving that's the only
way i don't think there's any other way
but the question is what aspects of
human nature do you have to encode into
the machine right so you have to solve
the perception problem like detect
and then you first
well realize
what is the perception problem for
driving like all the kinds of things you
have to be able to see like what what do
we even look at when we drive there's uh
i just recently
heard andre talked about at mit about
like car doors i think it was the
world's greatest talk of all time about
car doors yeah um the the you know the
fine details of car doors like what what
is even an open car door man
so like the the ontology of that that's
the perception problem we humans solve
that perception problem and tesla has to
solve that problem and then there's the
control and the planning coupled with
the perception you have to figure out
like
what's involved in driving like
especially in all the different edge
cases
and and then i mean
maybe you can comment on this
how much game theoretic kind of stuff
needs to be involved
you know at a four-way stop sign
you know our as humans when we drive our
actions affect the world like sure it
changes how others behave most
autonomous driving if you
you're usually just responding
um to the scene as opposed to like
really um asserting yourself in the
scene do you think
i think these actually i think i think
these could these sort of control
control logic conundrums are not are not
the hard part
um
the
you know
let's see um
what do you think is the hard part in
this whole
um beautiful complex problem so it's a
lot of freaking software man
a lot of smart lines of code um
for sure in order to have
um
create an accurate vector space
so
like you
you're coming from image space which is
like this this flow of
um photons you're going to camera
cameras and
and then uh
so you have this massive bitstream
um
in
image space and then you have to
effectively compress uh the
a massive
bit stream
uh corresponding to
photons that
knocked off an electron in a camera
sensor
uh and and turn that put stream into
into vector space um
i by by vector space i mean like
uh
you know you've got
cars and and humans and uh
lane lines and curves and
uh
traffic lights and that kind of thing
um
once you uh have an accurate vector
space um the control problem is similar
to that of a video game like a grand
theft auto cyberpunk um if you have
accurate best vector space it's the
control problem is
it's i wouldn't say it's it's trouble
it's not trivial but it's um
like it's it's it's it's a it's not like
some
insurmountable thing it's a it's but
having accurate vector space
is very difficult yeah i think we humans
uh
don't give enough respect to how
incredible the human perception system
is to mapping the raw
photons to the vector space
representation in our heads
your brain is doing an incredible amount
of processing um
and and giving you an image that is a
very cleaned up image like when we look
around here we see like you see color in
the corners of your eyes but actually
your eyes have very few uh
cones like the cone receptors in the
peripheral vision your your eyes are
painting color in the peripheral vision
you don't realize it but their eyes are
actually
painting color and
your eyes also have like this blood
vessels and all sorts of gnarly things
and there's a blind spot but do you see
your blind spot no your
your brain is painting in the missing
the blind spot you're gonna do these
like
see these things online where you look
look here and look at this point and and
then look at this point and it's
if it's in your blind spot it your brain
will just fill in the
the missing version
the peripheral vision is so cool yes you
realize all the illusions for vision
sciences so makes you realize just how
incredible the brain is the brain is
doing crazy amount of post-processing on
the vision signals from your eyes
um it's insane
so
um
and then and then even once you get all
those vision signals uh your
your brain is constantly trying to fig
to forget as much as possible so human
memory is
perhaps the weakest thing about the
brain is memory
so because memory is
so expensive to a brain and so limited
your brain is trying to forget as much
as possible and distill
the things that you see into
uh the smallest smallest amounts of
information possible so your brain is
trying to not just get to a vector space
but get to a vector space that is the
smallest possible vector space of only
relevant objects
um
and i think like
you can sort of look inside your brain
or at least
i can like when you drive down the road
and and try to
think about what your brain is actually
doing
consciously
and it's conscious it's it's
it's
it's like
you'll see a car that's you could
because you're you don't have cameras
you i don't have eyes in the back your
head on the side you know so you say
like but you you basically your your
head is like a
you know you basically have like
two cameras on a slow gimbal
um
and and what's your
and i say it's not that great okay you
and i is uh you know like um and people
are constantly distracted and thinking
about things and texting and doing all
sorts of things they shouldn't do in a
car changing radio station
so
having arguments you know is like um
so
so then like say like like
uh
like when's the last time you look right
and left and you know or and rearward um
or even diagonally
you know forward
to actually refresh your vector space
so you're glancing around and what your
mind is doing is is is trying to distill
um
the relevant vectors basically objects
with a position and motion
uh
and
and and and then uh editing that down to
the least amount that's necessary for
you to drive it does seem to be able to
uh edit it down or compress it even
further into things like concepts so
it's not it's like it goes beyond the
human mind seems to go sometimes beyond
vector space
to sort of space of concepts to where
you'll see a thing it's no longer
represented spatially somehow it's
almost like a concept that you should be
aware of like if this is a school zone
you'll remember that as a concept which
is a weird thing to represent but
perhaps for driving you don't
need to fully represent those things or
maybe you get those kind of
um
well you indirectly you need to like
establish vector space and then
actually have
predictions for
uh that those vector spaces so like um
you know like if uh
you know like you drive past
say say
a
a
a a bus and and you see that there's
there's people
before you drove past the bus you saw
people crossing the interstate like or
some just imagine there's like a large
truck or something blocking site
um
but you before you came out to the truck
you saw that there were some kids about
to cross the road
in front of the truck now you can no
longer see the kids but you you need to
be able but you would now know okay
those kids are probably gonna pass by
the truck and cross the road
even though you cannot see them so you
have to have um
memory uh
you need to remember that there were
kids there and you need to have some
forward prediction of what their
position will be it's a really hard time
of relevance so with occlusions
and computer vision when you can't see
an object anymore even when it just
walks behind a tree and reappears that's
a really really
i mean at least in academic literature
it's tracking through occlusions it's
very difficult
yeah we're doing it
i understand this yeah
so some of it it's like object permanent
it's like same thing happens with the
humans with neural nets like when like a
toddler grows up like there's a there's
a point in time where
uh
they develop they have a sense of object
permanence so before a certain age if
you have a ball
uh or a toy or whatever and you put it
behind your back and you pop it out if
they don't before they have object
permanence it's like a new thing every
time it's like whoa this toy went poof
just faired and now it's back again and
they can't believe it and that they can
play peekaboo all day long because this
peekaboo is fresh every time
[Laughter]
but then we figure out object permanence
then they realize oh no the object is
not gone it's just behind your back
um sometimes i wish we never did figure
out objective permanence
yeah so that's uh
that's an important problem to solve
yes so so
like an important evolution of the
neural nets in the car is
uh
um
memory card
memory across both time and space um so
now you can't remember like you have to
say like how long do you want to
remember things for and and it's it
there's there's a cost to remembering
things for a long time so you could you
know like run out of
memory to if you try to remember too
much for too long
um and and then you also have things
that are stale if if they're
remember them for too long and then you
also need things that are
remembered over time so even if you
like say have like
fragrance like five seconds of memory uh
on a time basis but like let's say you
you're parked at light and you and you
saw
you use a pedestrian example that people
were waiting to cross the
across the road and you can't you can't
quite see them because of an occlusion
uh
but they might wait for a minute before
the light changes for them to cross the
road you still need to remember that
that that's where they were
um and that they're probably going to
cross the road type of thing um so even
if that exceeds your
your your time-based memory should not
exceed your space
memory
and i just think the data engine side of
that so getting the data to learn all
the concepts that you're saying now is
an incredible process it's this
iterative process of just it's this this
hydrogen at many parts
we're changing the name to something
else okay i'm sure it would be equally
as yeah rick and morty like there's a
lot of
we've re-architected the neural net uh
the neural nets in the cars so many
times it's crazy
oh so every time there's a new major
version you'll rename it to something
more ridiculous or
uh or memorable and beautiful sorry not
ridiculous of course
if you see the full the full like uh
array of neural nets that that that are
operating in the car it kind of boggles
the mind there's so there's so many
layers it's crazy um
so
yeah
um but
and we
we started off with
uh
simple neural nets that were uh
basically
image recognition on a single frame
from a single camera
uh and then
uh trying to knit those together with
it you know it with the
c
i should say we
we're really primarily running c here
because c plus plus is
too much overhead and we have our own c
compiler
so to get maximum performance we
actually wrote rotor and c compiler and
are continuing to optimize our c
compiler uh for
maximum efficiency in fact we've just
recently
uh done a new rev on a c compiler that
will compile directly to our autopilot
hardware so you want to compile the
whole thing down and with your own
compiler yeah like so efficiency here
because there's all kinds of compute
there's cpu gpu there's like basic types
of things
and you have to somehow figure out the
scheduling across all those things and
so you're compiling the code down yeah
it does all okay
this is so that's why there's a lot of
people involved
there's a lot of hardcore
software engineering at a very sort of
bare metal level uh because
we're trying to do a lot of compute
that's constrained to
the
you know our full self-driving computer
so and we want to try to have the
highest frames per second
um possible
um
within a sort of very finite amount of
compute um
and power so
um we really put a lot of effort into
the efficiency of our compute
um
and and uh so there's actually a lot of
work done by
some very talented software engineers at
tesla that
uh at a very foundational level to
improve the efficiency of compute and
how we use the
the trip accelerators uh which are
basically um
dot you know uh doing matrix math dot
products
like a brazilian dot products
and it's like what what are neural nets
it's like
compute wise like 99
dot products
so
you know
and you want to achieve as many
high frame rates like video game you
want yeah full resolution
high frame rate high frame rate low
latency
um
low jitter uh so
um
i think one of the things we're um
moving towards now is no post processing
of the
image through the um
the image signal processor so um
like for what happens for
cameras is that almost all cameras is
they
um
there's a lot of post processing done in
order to make pictures look pretty
and so we don't care about pictures
looking pretty um we we just want the
data we so we're removing just raw
photon counts
so the system will
like the
image that
that the computer sees is actually much
more than what
you see if you're represented on a
camera it's got much more data
and even in very low light conditions
you can see that there's a small photon
count difference between
you know
this spot here and that's about there
which means that so it can see in the
dark incredibly well
um because it can detect these tiny
differences in photon counts
like much better than you'd
possibly imagine
um so
and and then we also save
uh 13 milliseconds on a latency uh
so
um from removing the post processing in
the image yes yeah it's like um
because we've got you know eight cameras
and and then there's uh
roughly i don't know one and a half
milliseconds or so
maybe 1.6 milliseconds of latency um
for each camera and so
like
uh
um
going to just uh
basically bypassing the image processor
uh gets us back 13 milliseconds of
latency which is important
um
and we track latency all the way from
you know photon hits the
the camera to
you know all the steps that it's got to
go through to get you know go through
the
um
the various neural nets and the the c
code and
there's a little bit of c plus plus
there as well
um
well i can maybe a lot but it the the
core stuff is the heavy duty computers
will see um
and uh
and so so we track that latency all the
way to an output command to the um
drive unit to accelerate
the brakes just to
slow down the steering you know turn
left or right um
so because you got to output a command
that's going to go to a controller and
like some of these controllers have an
update frequency that's maybe 10 hertz
or something like that which is slow
that's like now you lose 100
milliseconds potentially
so
um so then we want to update the
the drivers on the
like steering and braking control to
have um
more like uh 100 hertz instead of 10
hertz and you could have 10 milliseconds
latency instead of 100 milliseconds
worst case latency and actually jitter
is more of a challenge than than latency
because latency is like you can you can
you can anticipate and predict but if
you're but if you've got a stack up of
things going from the camera to the to
the computer
through then a series of other computers
and finally to an actuator on the car if
you have a stack up of
uh
of tolerances of timing tolerances then
you can have quite a variable latency
which is called jetter and and that
makes it
hard to to anticipate exactly what how
you should turn the car or accelerate
because
you know if you got maybe
150 200 milliseconds of jitter then you
could be off by you know after 0.2
seconds and this can make this could
make a big difference so you have to
interpolate somehow to to
to uh deal with the effects of jitter so
that you can make like
robust controlled decisions
the again you have to uh so the jitters
and the sensor information or the jitter
can occur at any stage in the pipeline
you can if you have just if you have
fixed latency you can anticipate um
and and uh like say okay we know that uh
our information is for argument's sake
150 milliseconds stale
like so for um
145 milliseconds from
photons taking camera to um
where you can measure a change in the
acceleration of the vehicle
um
so
then uh then you can say okay well we're
gonna
and we know it's 150 milliseconds so
we're going to take that into account
and uh
and compensate for that latency however
if you've got then 150 milliseconds of
latency plus 100 milliseconds of jitter
that's which could be anywhere from zero
to zero to 100 milliseconds on top so
then your latency could be from 150 to
150 milliseconds now you got 100
milliseconds that you don't know what to
do with
and and that's basically random
so getting rid of jitter is extremely
important
and that affects your control decisions
and all those kinds of things
okay
um yeah the car is just going to
fundamentally maneuver better with lower
jitter um
the cars will maneuver with superhuman
ability and reaction time much faster
than a human
i mean i think over time the
autopilot full self driving will be
capable of maneuvers that um
you know
uh
you know are far more than what like
james bond could do in like the best
movie type of thing that's exactly what
i was imagining in my mind as you said
um it's like an impossible maneuvers
that a human couldn't do you know so
well let me ask sort of uh looking back
the six years looking out into the
future based on your current
understanding how hard do you think this
is this full self-driving problem when
do you think tesla will solve level four
fsd
i mean it's looking quite likely that it
will be next year
and what does the solution look like is
it the current pool of fsd beta
candidates
they start getting greater and greater
as they have been
degrees of autonomy and then there's a
certain
level beyond which
they can they can do their own they can
read a book
yeah so
uh
i mean you can see anybody who's been
following the
fossil driving beta closely
will see that the um
the
rate of disengagements has been dropping
rapidly
so like a disengagement b where where
the driver intervenes to prevent the car
from doing something right uh
dangerous potentially so
um
so the interventions
you know per million miles has been
dropping uh dramatically at some point
the
and that
trend looks like it happens next year is
the the the
probability of an accident on fsd uh is
uh less than that of the average human
and then and then significantly less
than that of the average human um so
it certainly
appears like we will get there next year
um
then of course
that then there's going to be a case of
okay we now have to prove this to
regulators and prove it to you know and
and we we want a standard that is not
just equivalent to a human but
uh much better than the average human i
think it's got to be at least two or
three times uh higher
safety than a human so two or three
times lower probability of injury than a
human
before before we would actually say like
okay it's okay to go it's not going to
be equivalent it's going to be much
better
so if you look uh 10 point fsd
10.6 just came out recently 10.7 is on
the way
maybe 11 is on the way somewhere in the
future yeah um we were hoping to get 11
out this year but it's uh
11 actually has a whole bunch of uh
fundamental rewrites on the neural
neural net architecture
and some
fundamental improvements
in
creating vector space
uh so
there is a some fundamental like leap
that really deserves the 11. i mean
that's a pretty cool number yeah yeah
uh 11 would be uh
a single stack for all you know one
stack to rule them all um
and uh
but but there's just some really
fundamental
uh
neural net architecture changes that are
that that will allow for
uh much more capability but but
you know at first they're gonna have
issues so like we have this working on
like sort of alpha software and it's
it's good but it's uh
it's it it's basically taking a whole
bunch of c c plus code and and deleting
a massive amount of c plus plus go and
replacing it with the neural net and you
know andre um makes this point a lot
which is like neural nets like kind of
eating software
you know over time there's like
less and less conventional software more
and more neural net we're just still
software but it's you know
still comes out the lines of software
but
uh let's just more more neural net stuff
uh and less
uh
you know heuristics basically um
if you're
more more more uh matrix based
stuff and less uh
heuristics based stuff um
and um
you know like like like one of the big
changes will be um
like right now the neural nets
uh will
um
deliver a giant bag of points
to the c plus plus or c and c plus plus
code yeah um
we call the giant bag of points yeah uh
and it's like so you go to pixel and and
and
something associated with that pixel
like this pixel is probably car the
pixel is probably lane line
then you've got to assemble this giant
bag of points
in the c code and turn it into
vectors
and it does a pretty good job of it but
it's
it's a
it's
we want to just we need another layer of
neural nets on top of that to take the
giant bag of points
and distill that down to
uh vector space in the neural net part
of the software as opposed to the
heuristics
part of the software
this is a big improvement
um you know that's all the way down it's
what you want it's not even your only
realness but it's it's it's uh this will
be just a ga this is a game changer to
not have the bag of points the giant bag
of points that has to be assembled with
um many lines of cfc plus plus uh and
and have the
and have a neural net just assemble
those into a vector so so that the
neural net is outputting
um
much much less data it's it's it's
outputting this this is a lane line this
is a curve this is drivable space this
is a card this is a you know a
pedestrian or a cyclist or something
like that it's outputting
um
it's really outputting
um profit vectors to
the
the cc plus less control control code as
opposed to
this sort of
constructing the the vectors
uh in c
um
which we've done i think quite a good
job of but it's it's a it you're kind of
hitting a local maximum on the how well
the c can do this
um
so this is this is really this is really
a big deal
and and just all of the networks in the
car need need to move to surround video
there's still some legacy networks that
are not surround video
and all of the training needs to move to
surround video and the efficiency of the
training uh it needs to get better and
it is
and then we need to move everything to
uh raw
uh photon
counts as opposed to um
processed images okay so which is just
quite a big reset on the training
because the system's trained on post
processed image images so we need to
redo all the training
uh
to train against the the
raw photon accounts instead of the
post-processed image so ultimately it's
kind of reducing the complexity of the
whole thing so uh reducing reducing
lines of code will actually go lower
yeah that's fascinating
um so you're doing fusion of all the
sensors so reducing the complexity of
having to deal with these cameras
cameras really right yes
um same with humans
yeah well i guess we got years too okay
yeah well we'll actually need to
incorporate um sound as well um because
you know you need to like listen for
ambulance sirens or you know fire trucks
you know uh
somebody like
you know yelling at you or something i
don't know just that there's there's a
little bit of audio that needs to be
incorporated as well do you need a
cookie bath break yeah we listen to the
trolls take a break okay
honestly frankly
like the ideas are the easy thing and
the implementation is the hard thing
like the idea of going to the moon is is
the easy part but going to the moon is
the hard part it's the hard part um and
there's a lot of like hardcore
engineering that's got to get done
at the hardware and software level uh
likes it optimizing the c compiler and
just you know uh
cutting out latency
everywhere
like this is
if we don't do this the system will not
work properly um so
the work of the engineers doing this
they are like the unsung heroes you know
but they are critical to the success of
the situation
i think you made it clear i mean at
least to me it's super exciting
everything that's going on outside of
what andre is doing
yeah just the whole infrastructure of
the software
i mean everything is going on with data
engine uh whatever whatever it's called
the whole process is just
the scale of it is boggle's mind like
the training the amount of work done
with like we've written all this custom
software for training and labeling
um and to do order labeling auto
leveling is essential
um
because especially when you've got like
surround video
it's very difficult to like label
surround video from scratch is extremely
difficult um
like take a human
such a long time to even label one video
clip like several hours
or the order label it
basically would just apply like heavy
duty
uh
like a lot of compute to the to the
video clips um
to pre-assign
and guess what all the things are that
are going on in the surround video and
then there's like correcting it yeah and
then all the human has to do is like
tweet like say this you know chan adjust
what is incorrect this this is like
increasing increases productivity by
effect 100 or more
yeah uh so you've presented teslabot as
primarily useful in the factory first of
all i think humanoid robots are
incredible from a fan of robotics i
think
uh the elegance of movement that cuba um
the humanoid robots the bipedal robots
show are just so cool so it's uh really
interesting that you're working on this
and also talking about applying the same
kind of all the ideas of some of which
we've talked about with data engine all
the things that we're talking about with
tesla autopilot just uh transferring
that over to the just yet another
robotics problem
i have to ask since i care about human
robot interaction so the human side of
that so you've talked about mostly in
the factory do you see it uh also do you
see part of this problem that tesla bot
has to solve is interacting with humans
and potentially having a place like in
the home
so interacting not just sure not
replacing labor but also like
i don't know
being a friend
or an assistant yeah i think the
possibilities are
you know endless
yeah i mean it's it's obviously like a
it's not quite in tesla's primary
mission direction of accelerating
sustainable energy but
it is a
an extremely useful thing that we can do
for the world which is to make a useful
humanoid robot
that is capable of
interacting with the world and
helping in in many different ways uh so
certainly in fact reason and really just
just i mean i think if you say like
uh
extrapolate to you know many years in
the future it's like
i i think
uh work will become optional
so
like there's a lot of jobs that
if you if
people weren't paid to do it they would
they wouldn't do it like it's not it's
not fun you know necessarily like
if you're washing dishes all day it's
like
you know
even if you really like washing dishes
you really want to do it for eight hours
a day every day probably not so
um and then there's like dangerous work
and basically if it's dangerous boring
uh has like
potential for repetitive stress injury
that kind of thing um
then that's really where
humanoid robots would add the most value
initially
um so that's
what we're aiming for is is to um
for the human robots to do jobs that
people don't don't voluntarily want to
do
um
and then we'll have to pair that
obviously with some kind of universal
basic income in the future
so
i think um
so do you see a world when there's like
hundreds of millions of tesla bots
doing different performing different
tasks throughout the world
yeah i haven't really thought about it
that far into the future but i guess
that there may be something like that um
so
ask a wild question so
the the number of tesla cars has been
accelerating there's been close to 2
million produced many of them have
autopilot i think we're over 2 million
now yeah
do you think there will ever be a time
when there will be more tesla bots
than tesla cars
yeah i i i i
you know actually it's funny you asked
this question because normally i do try
to think
pretty far into the future but i haven't
really thought that far into the future
with the with the
tesla bot or it's code named optimus
i call it optimus subprime
because that's not it's not like a giant
you know transformer robot um
so
uh
but it's meant to be a general purpose
help help robot
um
and and basically like like the things
that were
basically
like tesla
i think um is the has the most advanced
real-world ai
uh for interacting with the real world
which we've developed as a function of
to to make self-driving work
um and so
along with custom hardware and
like a lot of
you know uh hardcore low-level software
to have it run efficiently and be you
know power efficient because because you
know it's one thing to do neural nets if
you've got a gigantic server room with
10 000 computers but now let's say you
just you have to now distill that down
into
one computer that's running at low power
in a humanoid robot or a car
that's actually very difficult a lot of
hardcore software work is required for
that
um
so
so since we're kind of like solving the
navigate the real world
with neural nets problem for
cars which are kind of like robots with
four wheels
then it's like kind of a natural
extension of that is to
put it in a robot with arms and legs uh
and actually you know actuators um
so
um
like like the the two
like the hard things are like you
basically need to make the
have the rower be intelligent enough to
interact in a sensible way with the
environment
um
so you need real real world ai and you
need
to be very good at um manufacturing
which is a very hard problem tails is
very good at manufacturing
and also uh has the real world ai so
making the humanoid robot work is
uh basically it means developing
custom
motors and sensors
that that are different from what a car
would use
um
but we also we have
um
i think with the the best expertise in
developing advanced electric motors and
power electronics so
it just has to be for
humanoid robot application on a car
still you do talk about love sometimes
so let me ask this isn't like for like
sex robots or something i love is the
answer
yes
uh
there is something compelling
to us not compelling but we connect with
the
humanoid robots or even lego robots like
with the dog and she shapes with dogs
it just it seems like you know there's a
huge amount of loneliness in this world
all of us seek companionship and with
other humans friendship and all those
kinds of things we have a lot of here in
austin a lot of people have dogs
there seems to be a huge opportunity to
also have robots that decrease
the uh
the the amount of loneliness in the
world or help us humans connect with
each with each other
so in a way that dogs can
um do you think about that we test about
it all or is it really focused on the
problem of
of performing specific tasks not
connecting with humans
um
i mean to be honest i have not actually
thought about it from the companionship
standpoint but i think it actually would
end up being it could be actually a very
good companion
um
and
it could
develop like a personality
uh
over time that is that is like
unique like uh you know it's not like
they're just all the robots are the same
and that personality could evolve
to be you know uh
match match the the the owner or the you
know or i guess
the owner uh well
whatever you want to call it uh the
other the companion the other half right
uh the same way their friends do see i
think that's a huge opportunity i think
yeah no that's interesting
like um
the
because you know like there's a
japanese phrase i like the uh
wabi-sabi you know uh the subtle
imperfections
are what makes something special
and the subtle imperfections of the
personality of the robot
mapped to the subtle imperfections of
the robot's
human friend i don't know owner sounds
like maybe the wrong word but
um
could actually make an incredible buddy
basically and in that way the r2d2 or
like a c-3po sort of thing you know so
from a machine learning perspective
i think the flaws
being a feature is really nice you could
be quite terrible at being a robot for
quite a while
in the general home environment or all
the in general world and that's kind of
adorable and that's like those are your
flaws and you fall in love with those
flaws so it's it's
very different than autonomous driving
where it's a very high stakes
environment you cannot mess up
and so
yeah it's more fun to be a robot in the
home
yeah in fact if you think of like c-3po
and
r2d2 yeah like they actually had a lot
of like flaws and imperfections and
silly things and they would argue with
each other
and um were they actually good at doing
anything
i'm not exactly sure
they definitely added a lot to the story
um
but but there's they're sort of quirky
elements and
you know
that they would like make mistakes and
do things like it was like uh it made
them
relatable i don't know um
endearing
so
so yeah i think that that could be
something that uh probably would happen
um
but our initial focus is just to make it
useful uh so that so
um
i'm confident we'll get it done i'm not
sure what the exact time frame is but uh
like we'll probably have i don't know
a decent prototype
towards the end of next year or
something like that
and it's cool that it's connected to
tesla the car
the so so yeah
it's using a lot of you know it would
use the autopilot inference computer and
um a lot of the training that we've done
for the four cars in terms of
recognizing
real world things could be applied
directly to the
to the robot um
so it but but there's there's a lot of
custom actuators and sensors that need
to be developed
and an extra module on top of the vector
space
uh for love
oh yeah that's missing
okay okay add that to the car too
that's true
um
that could be useful in all environments
like you said a lot of people argue in
the car so maybe people can help them
out
uh you're a student of history fan of
dan carlin's hardcore history podcast
yeah that's great greatest podcast ever
yeah i think it is actually
i i it does it almost doesn't really
count as a podcast yeah it's it's it's
more like a audiobook yeah so you were
on the podcast with dan i just had to
chat with him about it
he said you guys want military and all
that kind of stuff uh yeah it's
literally uh it was basically um
uh
i think it should be titled engineer
wars uh essentially like like when
there's a rapid change in the rate of
technology
then uh
engineering plays a pivotal role in in
victory in battle
um
how far in back in history did you go
did you go world war ii
uh it was mostly
well it was supposed to be a deep dive
on fighters and bomber
uh technology in world war ii um but
that ended up being more wide-ranging
than that um
because i just went down the total rat
hole of like
studying all of the fighters and bombers
world war ii and like the constant rock
paper scissors game that like you know
uh one country would make this plane
that would make a plane to beat that and
that try to make plane to beat that and
then
and really what matters like the pace of
innovation um and also access to high
quality uh
fuel and uh raw materials
so like germany had like some amazing
designs but they couldn't make them uh
because they couldn't get their raw
materials
and uh
they they had a real problem with the
oil and and and uh fuel basically the
fuel quality was extremely uh variable
so the design wasn't the bottom that
goes uh yeah like the us had kick-ass
fuel uh that was like very consistent
like the problems if you make a very
high performance aircraft engine um in
order to make high performance you have
to um
the the
the fuel the aviation gas uh
has to be a consistent mixture and uh
uh it has to have a high high octane
um
like high octane is the most important
thing but also can't have like
impurities and stuff uh because you'll
fill up the engine and and and german
just never had good access oil like they
tried to get it by invading the caucasus
um but that didn't work too well
[Laughter]
that never works well for him
that's nice for you so they always was
germany was always struggling with [ __ ]
with basically shitty oil um and then
they could not uh
they couldn't count on a on high quality
fuel for their aircraft so then they had
to add all they have all these additives
and and stuff
uh so um
uh whereas the u.s had awesome fuel um
and that provided that to britain as
well um so
that allowed the british and the
americans to design aircraft engines
that were uh super high performance
better than anything else in the world
and germany germany could could design
the engines they just didn't have the
fuel and then also the likes of the the
uh the quality of the aluminum allies
that they were getting was also not that
great and so yeah did you is this like
uh you talked about all this with dan
yep awesome
broadly looking at history when you look
at genghis khan when you look at stalin
hitler the darkest moments of human
history
uh what do you take away from those
moments does it help you gain insight
about human nature about human behavior
today
whether it's the wars or the individuals
or just the behavior of people any
aspects of history
yeah i find history fascinating
um
there's a lot of incredible things that
have been done good and bad um
that they
help
help you understand
the nature of
civilization um
and individuals and
does it make you sad that humans do
these kinds of things to each other you
look at the 20th century world war ii
the cruelty the abuse of power
talk about
communism marxism and stalin um
i mean some of these things do i mean if
you
like there's a lot of human history um
most of it is
actually people just getting on with
their lives uh you know and and it's not
like
human history is just
uh what nonstop war and
disaster is it's those are actually just
those are intermittent and rare and if
they weren't then
you know humans would soon cease to
exist
um
uh but
it's just that wars tend to be written
about a lot and whereas like uh
something being like well a normal year
where nothing
major happened was doesn't get written
about much but that's
you know most people just like farming
and kind of like living their life you
know
being a villager
somewhere
and every now and again there's a war
and i think so
um and um you know what i'll say like
that
there aren't very many books that i
where i just had to stop reading because
it was just too
too dark
but uh
the book about stalin the court of the
reds are
i could have stopped reading it was just
too too bad
dark
rough
yeah
um the 30s
uh there's a lot of lessons there to me
in particular that it feels like
humans like all of us have that as the
old soldier knits in line
um that the line between good and evil
runs to the heart every man that all of
us are capable of evil all of us are
capable of good it's almost like this
kind of responsibility that
um all of us have to
to
to tend towards the good and so like to
me looking at history is almost like an
example of
look you have some charismatic leader
that uh convinces you of things it's too
easy
based on that story to do evil onto each
other onto your family and to others and
so it's like our responsibility to do
good
it's not like
now is somehow different from history
that can happen again all of it can
happen again
and yes most of the time you're right i
mean the optimistic view here is
mostly people are just living life and
as you've often memed about
the quality of life was way worse back
in the day and keeps improving over time
through innovation to technology but
still it's somehow notable that these
blimps of
atrocities happen sure
yeah i mean life was really tough
for most of history
i mean really for most of human history
a good year would be one where not that
many people in your village died of the
plague starvation freezing to death or
being killed by a neighboring village
it's like well it wasn't that bad you
know it was only like you know we lost
five percent this year that was uh
yeah it was a good year you know that
would be par for the course
like just just not starving to death
would have been like the primary goal of
most people in through throughout
history just making sure we'll have
enough food to last through the winter
and not get in our freezer or whatever
so
[Music]
um
now food is is plentiful if i have an
obesity problem um
you know so
well yeah the lesson there is to be
grateful for the way things are now for
for some of us
we've spoken about this offline
i'd love to get your thought about it
here
if i sat down for a long form in-person
conversation with the president of
russia vladimir putin
would you potentially want to call in
for a few minutes
uh to join in on a conversation with him
moderated translated by me
sure yeah sure i'd be happy to do that
you've shown interest in the russian
language
is this grounded in your interest in
history of linguistics culture
general curiosity i think it sounds cool
sounds cool now it looks cool so uh well
it's it's you know it's it's a
it takes a moment to read cyrillic
um
once you know what the sort like
characters stand for actually
then reading russian becomes a lot
easier because there are a lot of words
that are actually the same like bank is
bank
[Laughter]
um
and uh
so find the words that are exactly the
same and now you start to understand
cyrillic yeah if you can if you can
sound it out then yeah
it's much
there's at least some commonality of
words what about the culture
you uh you love great engineering
physics there's a tradition of the
sciences there sure you look at the 20th
century from rocketry so
you know some of the greatest rockets of
the space exploration has been done in
the soviet in the former soviet union
yeah so do you draw inspiration from
that history just how this culture that
in many ways i mean one of the sad
things is because of the language
a lot of it is lost to history because
it's not translated all those kinds of
because it it is in some ways an
isolated culture it flourishes within
its within its borders
um yeah so do you draw inspiration from
those folks from from the history of
science engineering there
i mean the soviet union russia and
ukraine as well
and uh
have a really
strong history in space flight like some
of the most advanced and impressive
things in history were done uh
you know by the soviet union um
so
[Music]
um
one can cannot help but admire the
impressive rocket technology that was
developed
um
you know after the sort of fall of
soviet union the
there there's
the
there's much less that that that
happened
um
but uh
still things are happening but it's not
not quite at the
um frenetic piece that was happening
before the soviet union kind of
dissolved into separate republics
yeah i mean i i you know there's ross
cosmos the russian
agency a um
i look forward to a time when those
countries with china are working
together uh in the united states they're
all working together maybe a little bit
of friendly competition but i think
friendly competition is good um
you know governments are slow and the
only thing slower than one government is
a collection of governments
so
yeah
the olympics would be boring if everyone
just crossed the finishing line at the
same time yeah nobody would watch yeah
uh and and people wouldn't try hard to
run fast and stuff so i think friendly
competition is a good thing
uh this is also a good place to give a
shout out to a video titled the entire
soviet rocket engine family tree by tim
dodd aka everyday astronaut it's like an
hour and a half it gives a full history
of soviet rockets
and people should definitely go check
out and support tim in general that guy
is super excited about the future super
excited about space flight every time i
see anything by him i just have a stupid
smile on my face because he's so excited
about stuff
yeah i love people like dad is real
really great if you're interested in
anything to do with space um he's in
terms of uh explaining
rocket technology to your average person
he's awesome the best i'd say
um
and um
i should say like the
part reason like uh
i switched us from
like rafter at one point was gonna be a
hydrogen engine
um
but but hydrogen has a lot of challenges
it's very low density it's a it's a deep
cryogen so it's only liquid at a very
you know very close to absolute zero
requires a lot of insulation it's um
so it is a lot of challenges there
and um
and i was actually reading a bit about
uh russian rocket engine development and
um
at least the impression i had was that
that uh
soviet union russia and ukraine uh
primarily were
uh actually in the process of
uh switching to meth methylox
um and there were some interesting tests
and data for
isp like they were able to get like
up to like a 380 second isp with the
meth lux engine and i was like whoa okay
that's
that's actually really impressive so
um
so i think we could you could actually
get
a much lower cost like in optimizing
cost per ton to orbit cost per time to
mars
it's uh
i think
methane auction is the way to go
and i was partly inspired by the russian
work on the test stands uh
with methodolox engines
and now for something completely
different
do you mind doing a bit of a meme review
in the spirit of the great the powerful
pewdiepie
let's say one to eleven just go over a
few documents print it out
we can try let's try this
i present to you document
numero uno
okay
vladimi paler discovers
marshmallows
that's so bad
so
you get it because uh yes are you
failing things it's like i know three
whatever
that's not very good
this is uh grounded in some engineering
some history
uh yeah give us an eight out of ten
what do you think about nuclear power
i'm in favor of nuclear power i think
it's uh
i i in a place that is not subject to
extreme natural disasters i think it's a
nuclear power is a great way to generate
uh electricity
um i i don't think we should be shutting
down nuclear power stations
yeah but what about chernobyl
exactly
um
so
[Music]
uh i think people there's like a lot of
fear of radiation and stuff um
and it's
i guess what the problem is like a lot
of people just don't
unders
they didn't study
engineering or physics so they don't
it's just the word radiation just sounds
scary you know so they don't they ha
they can't calibrate what radiation
means
but radiation is much less dangerous
than than you'd think
so
like for example fukushima you know um
when the fukushima uh problem happened
uh
do the tsunami the
i got people in california asking me if
they should worry about radiation
from fukushima i'm like
definitely not not even slightly not at
all
that is crazy
and
just to
show like look
this is how
like the dangers is so much overplayed
compared to what what it really
is that i actually flew to fukushima
and actually i donated a
a solar power system for water treatment
plant and
and i made a point of
eating locally grown vegetables
on tv
in fukushima
like
i'm still alive okay
so it's not even that the risk of these
events is low but the impact of them is
the impact is greatly exaggerated it's
just human nature
it's people who don't know what
radiation is like i've had people ask me
like what about radiation from cell
phones according to causing brain cancer
i'm like when you say radiation do you
mean photons or particles then like that
i don't know what what do you mean
protons particles so do you mean
uh
if
let's say photons what
what frequency or wavelength and they're
like no i have no idea um like do you
know that everything's radiating all the
time
like what do you mean like yeah
everything's radiating all the time
photons are being emitted by all objects
all the time basically so
um
and if you want to know what it's it's
what it means to stand in front of
nuclear fire
go outside
the sun is a gigantic
you know thermonuclear
reactor that you're staring right at it
are you still alive yes okay amazing
yeah i guess radiation is one of the
words that can be used as a tool to to
fear monger by certain people that's it
and i think people just don't understand
so i mean that's the way to fight that
uh that fear i suppose is to understand
is to learn
yeah just say like okay how many people
have actually died from nuclear
accidents it's like practically nothing
and uh say how many people have have
died from
you know coal
plants and it's a very big number
so
like obviously we should not be
starting up coal plants and shutting
down nuclear plants just doesn't make
any sense
at all
coal plants like i don't know a hundred
to a thousand times worse for for health
than nuclear power plants
uh you want to go to the next one
it's really bad
it's uh that uh
90 180 and 360 degrees everybody loves
the math nobody gives a [ __ ] about 270.
it's not super funny
yeah i don't like two or three yeah um
this is not a you know
lol situation
[Laughter]
that's pretty good the united states
oscillating between establishing and
destroying dictatorships it's like a
metro is that a matchup yeah
yeah yeah it's uh on a seven out of ten
it's kind of true oh yeah this is uh
this is kind of personal for me next one
oh man this is leica yeah well no is
this or it's like referring to like or
something as like as like
a
husband husband yeah yeah hello yes this
is dog your wife was launched into space
and then the last one
is him with his eyes closed and a bottle
of vodka
yeah like it didn't come back no
they don't tell you the full story of
you know what
what the love the impact they had on the
loved ones yeah true that one gets an 11
for me
oh yeah it just keeps going
on the russian theme
first man in space
nobody cares first man on the moon well
i think people do care no i know but um
there is uruguay gardens names will
will be forever in history i think there
is something special about placing like
stepping foot onto another totally
foreign land
it's it's not the journey like uh people
that explore the oceans it's not as
important to explore the oceans is to
land on a whole new continent
yeah
this is about you
oh yeah i'd love to get your comment on
this elon musk
after sending 6.6 billion dollars to the
u.n to end world hunger
you have three hours
um
you know i mean obviously six billion
dollars is not going to end with hunger
so
um
so
i mean the reality is at this point the
world is producing uh
far more food than it can really consume
like we don't have a
caloric uh
constraint to this point so where there
is hunger it is
almost always due to um
it's like like civil war or strife or
some like um
it's it's not a thing that is
it's extremely rare for it to be just a
matter of like
like lack of money it's like
you know it's like some to the civil war
in some some country and and like one
part of the country is literally trying
to starve the other part of the country
um
so it's much more complex than something
that money could solve it's politics
geopolitics it's it's
a lot of things it's human nature it's
governments it's monies monetary systems
all that kind of stuff
yeah food is extremely cheap uh these
days it's like it's
um
i mean the u.s at this point um
you know among low-income families
obesity is actually another problem it's
not
like obviously it's not hunger it's like
too much it's you know too many calories
uh so
it's not that nobody's hungry hungry
anywhere it's just it's just this is uh
not not a simple matter of adding money
and solving it
what do you think that one gets
just
this is going after empires world uh
where did you get those artifacts the
british museum
shout out to
monty python we found them
yeah the british museum is it's pretty
great i mean yeah it admittedly britain
did take uh these historical artifacts
from all around the world and put them
in london but uh you know it it's not
like
people can't go see them uh so it is a
convenient place to see these uh ancient
artifacts is is london for
you know for for a large segment of the
world
so i think you know on balance the
british museum is a net good
although i'm sure a lot of countries
argue about that yeah
it's like you want to make these
historical artifacts accessible to as
many people as possible
and the british museum
i think does a good job of that
even if there's a darker aspect to like
the history of empire in general
whatever the empire is
however things were done
this it is the history that happened you
can't sort of erase that history
unfortunately you could just become
better in the future
that's the point
yeah i mean it's like well how are we
gonna
pass moral judgment on these these
things like it's like if
uh
you know uh
if one is gonna judge say the rosh
empire you're gonna judge you know what
everyone was doing at the time
and how were the british relative to
everyone
um
and i think they would british would
actually get like a relatively good
grade relatively good grade not in
absolute terms but compared to
what everyone else was doing um
they were not the worst
like i said you gotta look at these
things in the context of the history at
the time um and say what what were the
alternatives and what are you comparing
it against yes and i
i do not think it will be the case that
um
britain would get a uh
a bad grade in in when looking at
history at the time you know if you
judge history from
you know
from
what is morally acceptable today you
basically are going to give everyone a
failing grade yeah i'm not clear it's
not i don't think anyone would get a
passing grade um
in in their morality uh of like you go
back 300 years ago like who's getting a
passing grade
basically no one
and we might not get a passing grade
from generations but uh that come after
us
uh what what does that one get
uh
sure uh success
for the monty python maybe i always love
monkey python they're great
uh brian and the quest for holy grail
are incredible yeah yeah yeah those
serious eyebrows
impressions
like you know how important is facial
hair to
great leadership well you got a new
haircut is that is that is this how does
that affect your leadership
i i don't know hopefully not
it doesn't um
yeah the second is no one
there's no one competing with brush i
have no one too those are like epic
eyebrows
so
sure
that's ridiculous six or seven i don't
know uh i like this like shakespearean
analysis of memes
he had he had a flair for drama as well
like you know
showmanship yeah yeah it must come from
the eyebrows all right um
invention great engineering look what i
invented yeah that's the best thing
since ripped up bread
yeah because they invented they're just
sliced bread am i just explaining memes
at this point
this is what my life has become
um
you know like a scribe that like runs
around with the kings and just like
writes down
memes
i mean when was the cheeseburger
inventor that's like an epic invention
yeah like
like wow
you know
that was versus just like a burger or a
burger i guess a burger in general it's
like you know um
then there's like what is a burger
what's a sandwich and then you start
getting as a pizza sandwich and what is
the original
it's it's it gets into an ontology
argument yeah but everybody knows like
if you order like a burger or
cheeseburger or whatever you like you
get like you know tomato and some
lettuce and onions and whatever and you
know
mayor and ketchup and mustard it's like
epic yeah but i'm sure they've had bread
and meat separately for a long time and
it was kind of a burger on the same
plate but somebody who actually combined
them into the same thing
and yeah bite and hold it make makes it
convenient it's a materials problem like
your hands don't get
dirty and whatever yeah it's brilliant
well that is not what i would have
guessed
but everyone knows like you you if you
order a cheeseburger you know what
you're getting you know it's not like
some obtuse like i wonder what i'll get
you know um
you know uh fries are
i mean
great i mean they were the devil but
fries are awesome um and
uh yeah chip pizza is incredible
uh food innovation doesn't get enough
love
yeah i guess is what we're getting at
it's great um
uh what about the uh matthew mcconaughey
austinite here uh president kennedy
do you know how to put men on the moon
yet nasa no president kennedy
be a lot cooler if you did
pretty much
sure six six or seven i suppose
that's the last one
that's funny
someone drew a bunch of dicks all over
the walls sistine chapel boys bathroom
sure i'll give it nine
it's that's really true
all right this is our highest ranking
meme for today i mean it's true like how
do they get away with that
lots of nakedness
i mean dick pics are
i mean just something throughout history
uh
as long as people can draw things
there's been a dick pic it's
a staple of human history it's a staple
consistent throughout human history you
you tweeted that you aspired to comedy
you're friends with joe rogan
might you uh do a short stand-up comedy
set at some point in the future
maybe um open for joe something like
that is that is that really stand-up
actual just blown stand-up full-on
stand-up is that in there or is that
i've never thought about that
um it's extremely difficult if
at least that's what the like joe says
and the comedians say
huh i wonder if i could um i mean only
one way to find out
you know i i have done
stand up for friends just uh
impromptu
you know i'll get get on like a roof uh
and they
they do laugh but they're friends too so
i don't know if if you gotta call you
know like a rumor strangers are they
gonna actually also find it funny but
i could try
see what happens
i think you'd learn something either way
um yeah i kind of love um
both the when you bomb and when when you
do great just watching people how they
deal with it is so difficult it's so
you're so fragile
up there it's just you
and you you think you're gonna be funny
and when it completely falls flat it's
just it's beautiful to see people
deal with like that uh you might have
enough material to do standard
no no i've never thought about but i
might have enough material um
i don't know like 15 minutes or
something oh yeah yeah do it do a
netflix special
netflix special sure
um what's your favorite rick and morty
concept uh
just to spring that on you is there
there's a lot of sort of scientific
engineering ideas explored there there's
the favorite one that's the butter robot
it's great uh yeah it's a great show
yeah
dragon ball is awesome
somebody that's exactly like you from an
alternate dimension showed up there elon
tusk
yeah that's right that you voiced yeah
rick morty suddenly explores a lot of
interesting concepts
i so like what's your favorite one i
know the the butter robot certainly is
uh
you know it's like it it's certainly
possible to have too much sentience in a
device
um like you don't want to have your
toast to be like
a super genius toaster it's gonna hate
hate life because well it could just
make us toast but if you know it's like
you don't want to have like super
intelligent stuck in a
a very limited device um do you think
it's too easy from uh if we talk about
from the engineering perspective of
super intelligence like with marvin the
robot like is it j it seems like it
might be very easy to engineer just a
depressed robot
like it sure it's not obvious to
engineer a robot that's going to
find a fulfilling existence
same as humans i suppose
but um
i wonder if that's like the default
if you don't do a good job on building a
robot it's going to be sad a lot
well we can reprogram robots easier than
we can reprogram humans
so
i guess if you let it evolve
without
tinkering then it might get sad
but you can change the optimization
function
and
have it be a cheery robot
you uh like i mentioned with with spacex
you give a lot of people hope and a lot
of people look up to you millions of
people look up to you uh if we think
about young people
in high school maybe in college
um what advice would you give to them
about
if they want to try to do something big
in this world they want to really have a
big positive impact what advice would
you give them about their career maybe
about life in general
try to be useful
um
you do things that are useful to your
fellow human beings to the world
it's very hard to be useful
um
very hard
um you know are you contributing more
than you
consume you know like uh
like can you
try to have a positive net contribution
to society um
i think that's the thing to aim for you
know not to try to be sort of a leader
for
just for the sake of being a leader or
whatever um
a lot of time people who
a lot of times the people you want as
leaders are other people who don't want
to be leaders
so
[Music]
um
if you live a useful life
that is a good life
a life worth
having lived
um
you know and i like i said
i would encourage people to
[Music]
use the mental tools of physics and
apply them broadly in life there are the
best tools when you think about
education and self-education what do you
recommend
so there's the university there's
uh self-study
there is a hands-on sort of finding a
company or a place or a set of people
that do the thing you're passionate
about and joining them as early as
possible
um
there's uh taking a road trip across
europe for a few years and writing some
poetry which uh which which trajectory
do you suggest
for in terms of learning about
how you can become useful as you
mentioned how you can have the most
positive impact
but i encourage people to read a lot of
books
just re like
basically try to ingest as much
information as you can
uh
and try to also just develop a good
general knowledge um
so you at least have like
a rough lay of the land of the the
knowledge landscape
um like try to learn a little bit about
a lot of things um because you might not
know what you're really interested how
would you know what you're really
interested in if you at least aren't
like doing it
peripheral exploration of broadly of
of
the knowledge landscape
um and you talk to people from different
walks of life and different uh
industries and professions and skills
and like what occupations like just try
you know
learn as much as possible
man search for meaning
isn't the whole thing a search for
meaning
is
yeah what's the meaning of life and all
you know
but just generally like i said i would
encourage people to read broadly
in many different subject areas um
and and and then try to find something
where there's an overlap of your talents
and
and what you're interested in so people
may be good at something but or they may
have
skill at a particular thing but they
don't like doing it
um
so you want to try to find a thing where
you ha you're
that's a good a good uh combination of
of your of the things that you're
inherently good at but you also like
doing
um
and um and reading is a super fast
shortcut to to figure out which where
are you you're both good at it you like
doing it and it will actually have
positive impact well you've got to learn
about things somehow so re reading
a broad range just really
read it
you know the more important one is that
kid i i
read through the encyclopedia uh so
that's pretty helpful
um
and uh
there's also things i didn't even know
existed or a lot so obviously it's like
as broad as it gets encyclopedias were
digestible i think
uh you know whatever 40 years ago
um
so
um
you know we read through the the
condensed version of the encyclopedia
britannica i'd recommend that
um you can always like skip subjects or
you read a few paragraphs and you know
you're not interested just jump to the
next one
so read the encyclopedia we're just
gonna
skim through it
um
and um
but you know i put a lot of stock and
certainly have a lot of respect for
someone who puts in an honest day's work
uh to do useful things
and
and just generally to have like not a
zero-sum mindset um
or or
like have more of a
grow the pie mindset like the
if you if you sort of say like
when when we see people like perhaps um
including some very smart people
kind of uh taking an attitude of uh like
like doing things that seem like morally
questionable
it's often because they have at a base
sort of axiomatic level a zero-sum
mindset
um and and they without realizing it
they don't realize they have a
zero-sum mindset or at least that they
don't realize it consciously
um and so if you have a zero-sum mindset
then the only way to get ahead is by
taking things from others
if if it's like if if
if the pie is fixed then the only way to
have more pie is to take someone else's
pie
but but this is false like obviously the
pie has grown dramatically over time the
economic pie
so
in reality you can have that
so overuse this analogy if you have a
lot of you can have there's a lot of pi
yeah it's not fixed um
so you really want to make sure you
don't you're not operating um
without realizing it from a zero-sum
mindset
where the only way to get ahead is to
take things from others then that's
going to result in you trying to take
things from others which is not not good
it's much better to work on
uh
[Music]
adding to the economic pie maybe you
know so
uh you know creating
like i said creating more than you
consume uh doing more than you
yeah um
so that that's a big deal um i think
there's like you know a fair number of
people in
in finance that
uh do have a bit of a zero-sum mindset
i mean it's all walks of life i've seen
that one of the one of the reasons
uh rogan inspires me he celebrates oh
there's a lot there's not not creating a
constant competition like there's a
scarcity of resources what happens when
you celebrate others and you promote
others
the ideas of others
it uh it actually grows that pie i mean
it the every like the uh the resource
the resources become less scarce
and that that applies in a lot of kinds
of domains it applies in academia where
a lot of people are very
uh see some funding for academic
research is zero sum and it is not if
you celebrate each other if you make if
you get everybody to be excited about ai
about physics above mathematics i think
it there'd be more and more funding and
i think everybody wins yeah that applies
i think broadly
yeah yeah exactly so last
last question about love and meaning
uh what is the role of love in the human
condition broadly and more specific to
you how has love romantic love or
otherwise made you a better person a
better human being
better engineer
now you're asking really perplexing
questions
um
it's hard to give up
i mean there are many
books poems and songs written about what
is love and
what is what exactly
you know um
you know what is love people don't hurt
me
um that's one of the great ones yes yeah
you've you've earlier quoted shakespeare
but that that's really up there yeah
let me that was the many splendor thing
uh
i mean there's um
it's because we've talked about so many
inspiring things like be useful in the
world sort of like solve problems
alleviate suffering but
it seems like connection between humans
is a source you know it's a
it's a source of joy it's a source of
meaning and that that's what love is
friendship love
i i just wonder if you think about that
kind of thing when you talk about
preserving the light of human
consciousness right and thus becoming a
multiplication multi-planetary species
i mean to me at least
um
that that means like if we're just alone
and conscious and intelligent it doesn't
mean nearly as much as if we're with
others
right and there's some magic created
when we're together
the
uh the friendship of it and i think the
highest form of it is love which i think
broadly is is much bigger than just sort
of romantic but also yes romantic love
and
um family and those kinds of things well
i mean the reason i guess i care about
us becoming a multi-planet species in a
space frank civilization
is
foundationally i love humanity
um
and and so i wish to see it prosper and
do great things and be happy and
um and if i did not love humanity i
would not care about these things
so when you look at the whole of it the
the human history all the people has
ever lived all the people alive now
it's pretty
we're we're okay
on the whole we're pretty interesting
uh bunch
yeah
both things considered
and i've read a lot of history including
the darkest worst parts of it
and uh and despite all that i think on
balance
i still love humanity
you joked about it with the 42 uh what
what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing
is like is there a non-numerical oh
yeah well really i think what douglas
adams was saying in hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy is that
um
the universe is the answer
and
uh
what
we really need to figure out are what
questions to ask about the answer that
is the universe yeah
and that the question is the really the
hard part and if you can properly frame
the question then the answer relatively
speaking is easy
so
so therefore if you want to understand
what
questions to ask about the universe you
want to understand the meaning of life
we need to
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness
so that we're better able to
understand the nature of the universe
and
and understand the meaning of life
and ultimately
the most important part would be to ask
the right question
yes uh
thereby elevating the role of the
interviewer
yes exactly as the most important human
in the room
good questions are
you know it's a hot it's hard to come up
with good questions
uh absolutely um
but yeah like it's like that that is the
foundation of my philosophy is that
um i i am curious about the nature of
the universe and
uh
you know and obviously i will die
i don't know when i'll die but i won't
live forever um
but i would like to know that we are on
a path to understanding the nature of
the universe and the meaning of life and
what questions to ask about the answer
that is the universe
and um and so if we expand the scope and
scale of humanity and consciousness in
general which includes silicon
consciousness then
that you know there were that that seems
like a fundamentally good thing
elon like i said
i'm deeply grateful that you would spend
your extremely valuable time with me
today and also that you are given
millions of people hope in this
difficult time this divisive time
in this uh cynical time so i hope you do
continue doing what you're doing thank
you so much for talking today oh you're
welcome uh thanks for your excellent
questions
thanks for listening to this
conversation with elon musk to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from elon musk himself
when something is important enough you
do it even if the odds are not in your
favor
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you